after eight seasons of build-up The
Namesake mother on CBS's How I Met Your
Mother was finally revealed in 2013 it
was one of the most anticipated moments
in TV history so the absolute perfect
actress had to be cast the producers
somehow found the right woman for the
job
I've been little-known actress named
Cristin Milioti here's what else you'd
appeared in both before it after How I
Met Your Mother
once Broadway fans of the New York
theater scene they recognized Milioti
from her stage work she's performed
steadily both on and off Broadway for
more than a decade most notably when the
2007 indie hit once with the dancers of
theater in 2011 Milioti played the
unnamed female lead earning a Tony Award
nomination for Best Performance by a
leading actress in a musical The
Sopranos while pursuing a career as a
stage actor in New York Milioti landed
roles in some TV productions based out
of the tri-state area including The
Sopranos toward the end of the HBO mob
dramas run Milioti played Catherine
sacrimoni daughter of john sacrimoni
Johnny Sack
the ruthless boss of the lupertazzi
crime family were the one who wanted a
big wedding Catherine your sister has
enough to deal with without the
commentary 30 rock another New York
based TV show that hired Milioti was
NBC's 30 rock
in 2011 Milioti portrayed a seemingly
shallow stand-up comedian named Abby
Flynn who effects a show called sexy
baby voice Tina Fey's Liz Lemon hires
her to be a writer for TGS with tracy
Jordan after a blog accuses the sketch
comedy show of being misogynistic I'm
gonna set the move woman you hired they
called in here
I have to take them I'm not wearing any
underwear Milioti has to do some high
wire comma casting as it turns out the
Abby Flynn tax is a ruse she's really a
comedian named Abby Grossman hiding from
a crazed ex-husband sleepwalk with me
stand-up comedian actor and writer Mike
Birbiglia has presented sleepwalk with
me as a one-man show a book and in 2012
a feature film in the largely
autobiographical dramedy about the
comedian's history of severe sleep
disorders along with his anxieties over
his career in romantic lines Milioti
portrayed Janet and and Miglia pre-big
Leah's sister the film was a critical
hit and played well on the festival
circuit when
audience award at the Sundance Film Fest
the wolf of wallstreet Milioti became a
full-time cast member of How I Met Your
Mother in the fall of 2013 right around
the same time as the release of the wolf
of wallstreet
a darkly comic biopic about the rise and
fall of disgraced stockbroker Jordan
Belfort played by Leonardo DiCaprio
Milioti portrayed Teresa Jordan sweet in
patients first wife later abandoned for
a blonde bombshell played by Margot
Robbie the Garden State native is 100%
New Jersey in the role with accented big
and bold is a 1980 tere a-to-z
unfortunately the very nature of her
role on How I Met Your Mother met
Milioti was out of work after the show's
final season but by fall 2014 Milioti
was already starring in another Network
become something of a successor to How I
Met Your Mother with its rom-com
sensibility and slow build storyline
NBC's a-to-z ain't tell the complete
story of relationship from the meet-cute
to the happily ever after or split bin
Feldman of Mad Men portrayed Andrew
opposite Milioti Zelda despite some
critical praise for the show and the
cast the series didn't attract much of
an audience and NBC broke up with A to B
after 13 episodes Fargo Milioti popped
up in a small but pivotal role when the
second season of FX is Fargo mo yachties
character is dying of cancer and her
appearance heartbreakingly links the
second season of the series with the
first in the seventy set second season
Milioti plays Betsy Silver's
wife of state trooper Lou their daughter
Molly grows up to be a cop too as played
by Allison Tommen and the 2006's first
season the Mindy project in 2015 silly
Adi scored a recurring role on the Mindy
project
she played Whitney a tough-as-nails
workaholic hedge fund manager Milioti
character appeared in five episodes
dating one of doctors in the sitcom
central medical practice and also
becoming a new if brief best friend for
Mindy Whitney is the financial genius
who helps the scatterbrain Mindy get her
finances in order
it also turns out Whitney's there
recovering cocaine addict giving Milioti
a chance to do some dark yet wacky
comedy
when we hang out tonight house nine five
works better for me given my situation
you know because five ten at the four
twenty of cocaine
oh yeah course alright thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love do
[Music]